geçen dersimizde neyden bahsetmiştik
atom modellerini anlatmıştık sonra atomu
kısaca böyle bir ayırmıştı daha sonra
anyan katyonda izotop izoton izobar bu
kavramlardan bahsetmiştik Peki bu
dersimizde ne yapacağız elektron
dizilimlerini daha sonra Periyodik
tabloda yer bulmayı periyodik sistemdeki
özelliklerden bahsedeceğiz Daha sonra da
Metal ametal soygaz yarım metal bunların
özelliklerinden bahsedeceğiz yani soru
çıkabilecek önemli bir kısım var Bugün o
zaman vakit kaybetmeyelim hazırsan
başlayalım Evet güzel insan şimdi ne var
periyodik tablodaki işte ne diyor işte
elementlerin periyodik sisteme yerleşim
esası diye bir şey var da bu periyodik
tablo ile ilgili çalışma yapan birçok
insan olmuştur bunu 8 sınıf müfredatında
anlatıyorlar ne vardı işte de briner
vardı newlands vardı desan coroa vardı
Daha sonra da işte meer Daha sonra işte
Daha doğrusu meer ve melev birlikte Daha
doğrusu aynı tabloyu çalışıyorlardı
benzer bir tabloyu çalışıyorlardı sonra
ne geliyordu mosley geliyordu glen
seaborg da bu işi noktalı oldu işte şu
anda ise bizim için önemli olan Mendel
ve mozley bugün bunlardan bahsedelim
bakalım ne diyor Mendel'in periyodik
sistemi nasıl bir şeydi biliyor musun
dostum Bu adam elementleri zaten 63 tane
element biliniyordu o zaman atom
kütlesine göre sıralamıştır ve
elementlerin fiziksel ve kimyasal
özelliklerini dikkate alarak bugünkü
günümüzdeki periyodik tabloya kısmen
benzeyen bir periyodik tablo meydana
getirmişti Fakat burada şöyle bir şey
vardı oluşturduğu periyodik sistemde
benzer özelliklere göre aynı sütuna
yerleştiriyor sıralıydı yerleri boş
bırakmıştı ve demişti ki yani elementler
bulunacak demişti yani bazı elementler
bulunacak ve benim tablom daki o boş
bıraktığım yerlere bu elementler
yazılacak demişti yani periyodik
tablosunda boş yerler bırakmıştı ve bu
boş yerlere bazı elementlerin bulunup
yerleştirileceğini söylemişti ki en
önemlilerinden bir tanesi Dur bakayım
Neredeydi o silisyumun altında bir
boşluk vardı Ha Şuradaki boşluktan
bahsediyoruz mesela şuraya diyor ki bir
element gelecek diyor silisyum a
benzeyecek diyor buna ekas silisyum
diyor silisyum benzeyen element bunun
yoğunluğu şöyle olacak diyor işte
kaynama noktası şu aralıklarda olacak
kütle numarası şöyle olacak falan diye
böyle yorumlar yapıyor ve o element
bulunduğunda germanyum elementi
Mendel'in dediklerinin çok yüksek oranda
doğru olduğu ortaya çıkıyor mesela yani
Öyle ilginç bir adam Ama tabii ki aynı
kutucuğa birden fazla element yaldızlı
durumlar da var ki bu da tabii ki
günümüzdeki periyodik tabloya göre bir
eksiklik olacaktır Ama çok önemli bir
buluş yapmış oluyor işte burada da bunu
anlatıyor bak mendelin periyodik
sisteminde silisyumun altındaki boşlukta
ne yapıyor ek silisyum diyor buradaki
özellikleri tahmin etmiş ve büyük ölçüde
de tutturmuş önemli bir insandır
mendeleev dediğimizde aklımıza ne
gelecek elementleri atom kütlesi ve
fiziksel kimyasal özelliklerine göre
sıralamıştır ifadesi gelecek dostum
sonra kim geliyor tabii ki Henry mosley
geliyor bu adamı Biz çok iyi tanırız O
da bizi çok iyi tanır onun şeyleri de
Ülkesi de bizi çok iyi tanır özellikle
1900 yılların başlarından bizi gayet iyi
tanırlar Mesela yüzmeyi iyi öğretiriz
Biz biliyorsunuz Eee onunla alakalı bir
bir şey var birazdan söyleyeceğim mozley
Mendel'in aksine elementleri atom
kütlesine göre değil atom numarasına
göre yani Proton sayısına göre ne
yapıyor sıralıyor çünkü bu adam bir tane
şey yapıyor X ışını spektrumu yla
elementlerin Proton sayılarını net
olarak belirliyor ve her elementin
Proton sayısının kendine özgü olduğunu
Yani böyle TC kimlik numarası gibi
kendine özgü olduğunu keşfediyor ve
sonra da periyodik tablosunu Buna göre
dizdiğim her kutucuğa bir tane element
geldiğini fark ediyor ve bu şekilde bir
periyodik tablo oluşturuyor ve oluş
oturduğu Periyodik tabloda ne yapıyor
şöyle dikey sütunlara Grup diyor yatay
satırlara ise periyot ifadesini
kullanıyor Toplamda 18 tane grup 7 tane
de periyot yazıyor bunların detaylarını
zaten söyleyeceğiz ve bu şeylere mesela
a grupları ve B grupları ismini veriyor
a grupları 1A 2A 3A 4A 5A 6a 7A 8A
Bunlar baş Grup elementidir a grupları
Bir de B grupları vardır ki Periyodik
tabloda şöyle yerleşir 3B 4B 5B 6b 7B 8B
8B 8B 1B 2B şeklinde sıralanmaktadır
Yani toplam 8B grubundan 10 Daha doğrusu
şöyle söyleyeyim B gruplarından 10 tane
bulunmaktadır ama 8B 3 tane grup
şeklinde bulunur ama bu karışıklığı
ortadan kaldırmak için yupak sağ olsun
1'den 18'e kadar numaralandırma yapmış
şöyle söylemiş 1A grubuna 1 grup 2A
grubuna 2 grup ki niye öyle uğraşıyorum
ki ha tablo üstünde göstereyim 1 A'ya 1
grup diyor 2 A'ya 2 grup diyor 3 A'ya 13
Grup diyor Hocam niye atladı birden
133'e bak Arada 10 tane B grubu var ya o
yüzden atladı 14 grup Grup 15 16 17 ve
18 Grup diyor şuraya 3 A'ya 3 B'ye özür
dilerim 3B yee ne diyor 3 grup 4B 4 Grup
5B 5 grup 6b işte 6 grup işte gidiyor
şuraya dikkat et 8 grup şurası 8 B'nin
ikincisi 9 Grup bu 10 grup 11 grup ve 12
grup şeklinde yupak böyle bir adlandırma
yapıyor bu da önemlidir bilmende fayda
var dostum daha sonra Ne diyorduk Ha
bunu söyledim işte 8 tane A grubu 10
tane B grubu var yani 8 tane B grubu da
bunun 3 tanesi 8 B şeklinde olunca
Toplamda 10 tane ne oluyor B grubu olmuş
oluyor işte 8 B'den 3 tane vardır
ifadesini kullanıyoruz a gruplarına baş
Grup elementi B gruplarına ise geçiş
elementleri ya da yan Grup elementi
ifadesini kullanıyoruz ve 1ci periyotta
Bak 1ci periyotta iki tane element
bulunmakta şu ve şu 2 periyotta 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 tane element bulunmakta 3
periyotta da 8 tane element bulunmakta 4
periyotta 18 element bulunuyor neden B
grupları artık 4 periyottan itibaren
başlıyor sonra 5 periyot da işte 18 tane
element içeriyor ama 6 ve 7 periyot 32
şer element içeriyor Çünkü orada
lantanitler ve aktinitler bulunuyor bak
şu lantanitler Burası aktinitler de
burası burada toplamda da şuralarda 32
şer element bulunmakta onu da söyleyelim
dostum İşte burada da onu söylüyor işte
6 ve 7 periyotta 32 şer element bulunur
6 periyotta lantanitler 7 periyoda İsa
aktinitler ismini veriyoruz dostum ve
periyodik sistemde bazı grupların özel
isimleri vardır ki bil Men gerekiyor 1A
grubu alkali metaller kim hariç hidrojen
hariç ilk element hariç dostum Bak şu
hidrojendir 1A grubunda bulunur ama
alkali metal değildir yani 1A grubu
elementlerinin hepsi alkali metaldir
yanlış bir ifadedir dikkat et veya 1A
grubundaki elementlerin hepsi metaldir
yine yanlıştır hidrojen [__] metaldir
orada burada unutmaman gereken önemli
bir detaydır 2A grubuna Toprak Alkan
metalleri ismini veriyoruz 3A grubuna
Toprak metalleri 4A grubu karbon grubu
5A grubu azot grubu 6a grubuna oksijen
grub ya da kalkojenler ismi verilmekte
7A grubu Halojen 8A grubu soygaz ya da
asal gaz ismini almakta B gruplarına
geçiş metalleri ya da geçiş elementleri
burada lantanit ve aktinit lere ise iç
geçiş elementleri ya da iç geçiş
metalleri ismini veriyoruz dostum Peki
Periyodik tabloda yer bulma nasıl oluyor
şöyle oluyor Periyodik tabloda elektron
dizilimlerini yapmamız lazım Peki bunu
nasıl yapacağız şöyle bir kuralımız var
bir katmandaki elektron sayısı maksimum
elektron sayısı 2n kare formülüyle
bulunmakta 2n karedeki buradaki n katman
sayısı o zaman 1ci katmanda ise 1 x 1in
karesinden Demek ki 1ci katman en fazla
2 elektron alabiliyor 2ci katman 2 x
2nin karesinden en fazla 8 elektron
alıyor 3 katman 2 x 3'ün karesinden 18
elektron alabiliyor 4C katmana 4 2 x 4ün
karesinden 32 elektron alabiliyor
diyoruz ama bu birinci kuralımız daı
ikinci Kural da şunu söyler son katman
en fazla 8 elektron almaktadır ve
elementler Periyodik tabloda artan atom
numarasına göre dizilir Yani şöyle 1 2
şöyle Bak 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 diye gidiyor
bak artan atom numarasına göre
sıralanmaktadır bunu da bilmen lazım o
zaman bak şimdi kurallarımızı
uygulayalım mesela 5 demiş ya 5 ne
olacaktır 1ci katmana 2 yazdık 2ci
katman 8'e kadar alabiliyordu Ama benim
elimde 3 kaldı 2'ye 3 yazdık mesela 9
diyor ikincisinde 2'yi yazdım geriye ne
kaldı 7 kaldı zaten 88'e kadar
alabiliyordu yazdık e şuraya geldik 15
2'yi yazdık 2 katman en fazla 8 alıyor
kaç etti toplam 10 etti E ama 15'e
ihtiyacım var Şuraya da 5 yazdım Mesela
şöyle olsaydı kalsiyum var mesela değil
mi 2'yi yazdım 8 yazdım 3 katman 18
alabildiğine göre buraya 10 yazarım
Hayır bu 2ci kurala muhalif oluyor çünkü
son katman 8'den fazla elektron almıyor
diyorduk böyle gösterip de 8 demek garip
oldu son katman 8'den fazla elektron
almaz yani 2 8 o zaman 8 2 şeklinde
olacak dostum kalsiyum Bu da önemli bir
ayrıntıdır o o zaman potasyumda 2 88
geriye 9 kaldı 9 yazamam çünkü son
katman 8'den fazla alamıyor 8 1 şeklinde
yazıyoruz dostum mesela burada bak
Berilyum demiş 2'yi yazdım geriye 2
kaldı Ah bitti mesela sodyum burada ne
sodyum değil sodyumdan önce azot var
burada 2'ye 5 yazdık buraya dikkat et
dostum Bak burada ne var + 1 yüklü diyor
değil mi bunun elektron sayısı kaçtır
10'dur elektron dizilimi elektron
sayısına göre yazılmaktadır yani bunun
ikisi 2 8'dir ama Proton sayısına göre
periyodik tablodaki yer bulunur onu
birazdan detaylıca zaten burada Mesela
11 ya eğer sodyum nötr olsaydı sodyum 11
olsaydı nötr halde 2 yazacaktım 8
yazacaktım geriye 1 kaldığı için Böyle
yazacaktım Hocam niye buraya 2 9
yazmadık E niye yazmadık Çünkü 2ci
katman 8'den fazla almadı Hemen aklına
geldi hocam buraya 18 yazılabiliyor oldu
E sen şurada hemen üstünü karaladın Bak
tekrar hatırlatıyorum Bu da ikinci
kuralla Muhalif ne diyor bak son katman
en fazla 8 elektron alır diyor 2 8 10
yaz Tamam son katman 8 elektron alıa
uymuyor O yüzden 10 yerine ne yazdım 8
sonra da 2 yazdım bu şekilde
tamamlıyorsun tamam mı dostum başka
başka mesela p -3 diyor -3 ile kaçı
toplarsam 15 eder 18'i Demek ki elektron
sayısı 18 18'e göre yazmam lazım yani 2
8 8 olacak bu ne S16 nötr halde o zaman
elektron sayısı da 16 2 8 10 etti 6 flor
-1 diyor bak o zaman burası 10 elektronu
var -1 ile kaçı toplarsam 9 eder 10 o
zaman 2 8 şeklinde yazacağım tamam mı
dostum artı yüklüğe zaten örnek
vermiştik Tamamdır Şimdi bak Önemli bir
şey herhangi bir element atomunun
elektron dizilimindeki katman sayısı
periyodik sistemdeki periyodunu son
katmandaki elektronlar İsa değerlik
elektronunu vermektedir Bu da Grup
numarasını belirlemektedir diyoruz B
gruplarından tyt müfredatında
bahsetmeyeceğim da bahsediliyor onu da
zaten 1 S 2 S falan filan diye bir
şeyler var onu zaten oraya geldiğinde
öğreneceksin Dediğim gibi biz sadece a
gruplarından bahsedeceğiz özel bir durum
vardır normalde bak şöyle bir şey var
helyum lan yazsak daha güzel olur helyum
2 bunun elektron dizilimi nedir 2'dir
Kaç tane katman yazdım bir tane katman
yazdım bu birinci periyot elementidir Ee
kaç elektron var değerlik elektron
sayısı 2 bak değerlik elektron sayısı 2
ama 2A grubu değildir Bu 2A grubu değil
özel durum 8A grubudur helyum özel durum
Bunu sakın unutma Bir daha tekrar
edeceğim zaten bunu Mesela buraya Neyi
vermiş bana hangi örnek vermiş Grup
numarası demiş ne bu Ha dur 7'yi vermiş
bak proton sayısı 7 şöyle azot 7 2'ye 5
kaç tane katman yazdım rengi
değiştirerek göstereyim 1 2 katman
yazdığıma göre 2ci periyot diyorum son
katmanda kaç elektron var 5 yani
değerlik elektron sayısı 5'tir o zaman
5A grubudur işte değerlik elektron
sayısıyla Grup numarası aynı olmayan bir
helyum var özel durum onu da bilmen
lazım Bakalım Şuradaki tabloya Ha bu
arada şunu da söyleyeyim bak şu Hatta
Şuradaki boşluğa yazacağım örnek
veriyorum mesela mesela oksijen 8E -2
çok önemli bir detaydır beni var ya can
kulağıyla dinle Dedi ki bunun elektron
dizilimi nedir ve periyodik tablodaki
yeri nedir diye sordu Bak bunun elektron
dizilimi 10 elektronu var Neden -2 ile
kaçı toplarsam 8 eder 10u Yani bunun
elektron dizilimi 2 8'dir ama bak
periyodik tablodaki yer diyorsa daima
Proton sayısına bakacaksın bak periyodik
tablodaki yer Buna göre yazılır tamam mı
Yani 2'ye 6 6'dır bu iki katman var
İkinci periyot son katmanda 6 elektron
var 6a grubu elementidir gidip de
elektron dizilimine göre yapmıyorsun
periyodik tablodaki yer Proton sayısına
göre yapılır elektron dizilimi elektron
sayısına göre yapılır onda Herhangi bir
sıkıntı yok ama periyodik tablodaki yeri
soruyorsa Proton sayısına bakacaksın çok
çok önemli bir şeydir tamam mı dostum o
zaman Gel şunları belirleyelim bunun
elektron dizilimi 2 zaten bir tane
katman yazdık Demek ki birinci periyot e
değerlik elektron sayısı şunun değerlik
elektron sayısı 2 ama 8A grubunda
bulunuyor özel durum demiştik şuna
bakalım 1 2 tane katman var 2ci periyot
diyoruz değerlik elektron sayısı son
katmandaki elektron sayısı 1 yani 1A
grubu şuna bakalım iki tane katman var
2ci periyot değerlik elektron sayısı 6
Demek ki 6a grubu şuna geldik ik tane
katman var 2ci periyot son katmanda 7
elektron var 7A grubu yani değerlik
elektron sayısı 7 şuna baktık 1 2 3
katman var 3ün periyot son katmandaki
elektron sayısı 4 4A grubu Elem çok
basit bir şeydir Bak şuraya baktık 1 2 3
katman var 3 periyot son katmanda 6
elektron var 6a grubu 1 2 3 periyot son
katmanda 8 elektron var 8A grubu 1 2 3 4
katman var 4 periyot son katmanda 2
elektron var 2A grubu elementi o zaman
bak çok ince bir nokta geldi Onu da
şöyle söyleyeyim Kusura bakmayın böyle
pelan ağrısı arada geliyor böyle
desteklemek zorundayım şöyle bir şey
söylemek zorundayız Dostum bak dedi ki
8A grubu elementlerinin hepsinin değer
elektron sayısı 8'dir şuna baktığında ne
kadar doğru geliyor ama helyuma bakarsan
yanlış olduğunu anlarsın Bak hepsinin
derse gitti helyum özel durum veya dedi
ki değerlik elektron sayısı 2 olanlar
daima 2A grubu elementidir Hayır bak
helyum 8A grubu elementi Bu ince bir
noktadır özellikle gelebilir onu da
söyleyeyim bak ÖSYM ne demiş 18 nötronu
17 protonu bulunan x diyor ki
taneciğinin katm elektron dizilimi 2 8 8
şeklindedir yazalım şuraya X'in 17
protonu varmış 18 nötronu varmış o zaman
kütle numarası 35 elektron dizilimi ise
2 8 8 şeklindeydi kaç elektronu var bak
dostum sayalım 2 8 daha 10 8 Daha 18
elektronu var Aha O zaman bunun yükü
nedir -1 değil midir Çünkü yükle
elektron sayısını topladığında sana bunu
vermesi lazım yükü -1 yani negatif
yüklüdür Doğrudur 17 elektronu vardır
Hayır 18 elektronu vardır x taneciği
diyor çünkü yani bu halinden bahsediyor
ama nötr x deseydi Evet 17 elektronu
vardır diyebilirdin Bu doğru mu ha bu
yanlış olarak bulduk Pardon katyondur
diyor Hayır yanlıştır gitti elektron
vermiştir Hayır -1 yüklü eksi elektron
almayı ifade eder yanlıştır 2ci ve 3C
katmanlarında toplam 10 elektron vardır
2ci ve 3C katmanlarında Toplam 16
elektron vardır gitti cevabımız Ne oldu
doğruyu sorduğu için B seçeneği oldu
ÖSYM durmamış sağ olsun ne güzel sorular
sormuş şöyle sığdır alım ekrana da He
sığdırdık bak B ne diyor bana bazı
Elektron dizilimlerini vermiş sağ olsun
Ee diyor ki bu Elementlerin periyodik
sistemdeki yerleri ile ilgili
ifadelerden hangileri doğrudur Bak iki
tane katman var son katmanda 2 elektron
var 2 periyot 1 A grubu şu ik katman var
son katmanda 7 elektron var 2 periyot 7A
grubu bunun 3 tane katmanı var 3 periyot
son katmanda 2 elektron var 2A grubu
bunun 3 tane katmanı var 3 periyot 8A
grubu diyoruz E buna bakarsak 4 katman
var 4 periyot son katmanda 2 elektron
var 2A grubu elementi diyoruz Bakalım
hangisi doğrudur flor elementi 2A
grubudur Hayır canım 7A grubudur ikinci
periyottadır oradan tuzak kurmuş lityum
elementi 3ün periyottadır Hayır canım
2ci periyot 1A grubu o da gitti kalsiyum
ve magnezyum elementleri Aynı grupta yer
alır 2A grubu 2A grubu doğru bu ifade
devam edelim diyor ki lityum ve flor
elementleri Aynı grupta yer alır lityum
1A grubu flor 7A grubu Aynı grupta değil
aynı periyotta bulunur ikinci periyot
diyebilirdi Argon ve kalsiyum
elementleri aynı periyottadır Hayır bu 4
periyot bu 3ün periyot gitti cevap Ne
oldu C seçeneği oldu hocam Keşke böyle
sorsalar Evet ara ara soruyorlar
gördüğün gibi bu seneki sorular Bir tık
daha böyle bir üst düzey olabilir ama
normalde kolay soruyorlar genellikle
Kimyayı Ama bundan sonra artık bir şey
diyemiyorum bazen zorlayabilir Biz de ne
yapacağız Tüm detayları öğreneceğiz Peki
elementleri sınıflandıralım dersek ne
vardı metaller vardı ametaller vardı
yarı metaller vardı bir de Soygazlar
vardı şimdi bunlarla ilgili Bah
bahsedelim İşte bu Periyodik tabloda
renklerle gösteriyorum ya Şurada benim
renk özürlü olduğumu zaten biliyorsunuz
Şuradaki renkleri Görüyorsun bak bu
ametalleri gösteriyor Şuradaki renkler
ametalleri gösteriyor şurada Turkuaz
gibi olanlar nedir işte yarı metaller
bölüğe sinirle gelen az subay terli
postalları attırdı gibi bir ifade
kullanabiliriz oganesson denilen en son
bulunan elementlerden bir tanesidir ki
daha henüz Hani ömrü o kadar kısa ki
yani saniyenin Bilmem kaçta kaçı yani
çok kısa süre olduğu için onunla ilgili
herhangi bir özellik bulunamıyor O
yüzden yapay elementlerden bir tane
olduğu için herhangi bir özellik
söyleyemiyoruz Onun için burada bak
Soygazlar var 8A grubundakiler
gösteriyor başka ne var işte şu en fazla
olanlar Zaten metaller koca periyodik
tabloyu kaplıyor Gördüğün gibi periyodik
tablo İşte bu şekilde yapabiliriz burada
Merdiven var ya işte bak bu merdiven çok
güzel ayırıyor merdiven aslında
metallerle ametalleri tam da merdiven
üstünde yarı metaller olacak şekilde
güzel bir şekilde ayırıyor dostum Ama
genel olarak şunu söyleyeyim diyebiliriz
1ci ve 1A 2A ve 3A grubu elementlerinin
metal olduğunu Görüyorsun bak a
gruplarından bahsedersek 1A grubunun
çoğu hidrojen hariç metal 2A grubunun
tamamı metal 3A grubunda Bor yarım metal
diğerleri metal Bak bunu böyle
söyleyebiliriz mesela 1A grubunda
hidrojen hariç metal 3A grubunda Bor
hariç hepsi metal diyoruz B grupları ve
iç geçiş elementlerine de yine ne
diyoruz metal diyoruz dostum Bak burada
bazı örnekler vermiş metallere nikeli
vermiş lityumu vermiş daha birçok örnek
sodyumu var demiri var kalsiyumu var
Varoğlu var bir sürü var civa da sıvı
halde Ama metaldir mesela ha Bak burada
da onu söylüyor CIA hariç oda
sıcaklığında hepsi katı haldedir bir tek
civa sıva haldedir Ama mesela 30
dereceyi geçseydi orada galyum da sıva
hale geçiyor fransiyumun da öyle bir
durumu var ama fransiyum radyoaktif
olduğu için çok fazla görmüyoruz
metaller yüzeyleri parlaktır bak zaten o
parlaklık bariz bir şekilde gözüküyor O
yüzden ışığı yansıtmaktadır dövülerek
tel ve levha haline getirilebilir şu
ifadeleri görebilirsin tel ve levha
haline getirilebilir dövülebilir
dövülebilir ifadesi ya da haddelenebilir
haddelenebilir yani şekil verilebilir
Bir de onu da söyleyebiliriz şekil
verilebilir ifadeleri kullanılır ki şu
an kullandığımız birçok metal öyle
şekillendirilmiştir metallerin genel
olarak erime ve kaynama noktaları
yüksektir genel olarak diyoruz Tabii ki
yoğunlukları ametal ve soygazlardan
genel olarak yüksektir ametallerle
iyonik bağlı bileşik yaparken kendi
aralarında alaşım yapmaktadırlar Bu da
önemli bir ayrıntıdır ve bileşik
oluştururken elektron vermeye
yatkındırlar yani katyon oluşturmak
ister
pozitif yüklü iyona dönüşürler metaller
tamam mı metaller negatif yük olmaz [__]
metaller dediğimizde ise 4A grubunda
karbon 5A grubunda azot fosfor 6a
grubunda oksijen kükürt Selenyum ve 7A
grubunda flor Klor brom iyot Bunlar
ametaller Bir de 1A grubunda hidrojen
var mesela en önemli nedir ametaller
imiz bunlardır Hatta bunu şöyle
kodlayabilir Haylaz Cenap Osmanla
fırlama Celal'in burnunu ısırdı Yani
bunlar bilmen gereken ametaller böyle
kodlayabiliriz Haylaz Cenap Osmanla
fırlama Celal'in burnunu ısırdı gibi bir
kodlama basit bir kodlama daha
ilginçleri var da burada söylemeye uygun
olmuyor Kusura bakmayın e mesela kükürt
katı haldeki bir ametal veya işte
selenyumu burada vermiş demiştik ya 6 A
grubunda Selenyum diye başka iyot katı
haldedir mesela karbon katı haldedir ama
gaz halinde olanlar var hidrojen var
flor var Klor var azot var Bunlar mesela
fosfor katı haldeki yine örnek olarak
verilebilir brom da sıvı haldeki bir
ametal Yani şunu söyleyebiliriz
ametaller kat katı sıvı gaz hallerinde
bulunabiliyorlar mı bulunabiliyorlar Oda
sıcaklığını işte söylüyor katı sıvı gaz
hallerinde bulunanları vardır mat
görünümlüdür L parlak olmazlar genel
olarak grafit hariç elektriği iletmezler
yani ametaller elektriği iletmez bir tek
grafit iletir yani kaleminizin ucu Sakın
ha gidip kalemin ucunu prize sokmayın
bunu söylediğim için de şu an pişmanım
hocam Ben deneyeceğim diye alta kesin
yorumlara yazacaklar var biliyorum ama
yapmayın dostum Bak çok tehlikeli bir
şeydir Gerçekten sağlam çarpar bu çinko
karbon piller var ya işte oradaki karbon
grafit mesela elektriği iletmektedir ama
diğer ametaller iletmemek yoğunlukları
erime ve kaynama noktaları metallerden
düşüktür genel olarak diyoruz bunu başka
tel ve levhe haline getirilemez yani
vurduğunda dağılmaktadır genel olarak
Eee doğada serbest halde iki atomlu veya
işte Çok atomlu molekül halinde
bulunabilmektedir hidrojen H şeklinde
bulamazsın h2d veya işte flor F şeklinde
bulamazsın f2d oksijen mesela O2 ya da
o3 şeklinde bulabilirsin kükürt S4 S8
şeklinde bulunabilmektedir yani
moleküler halde bulunabilmektedir onu da
söyleyelim metaller atomik halde
bulunabilmektedir veya bileşik halinde
ama ametaller molekül halinde
bulunabilmektedir Bunlar hem kendi
aralarında kovalent bağlı bileşik
yaparken hem de metallerle iyonik bağlı
bileşik yapabilmektedirler Yani hem
metalle hem ametallerle bileşik
yapabilme özelliğine sahiptirler bunu da
söyleyelim ve bileşik oluşurken yani
iyonik bağlı bileşik oluşurken elektron
almak isterler yani negatif yüklü anyon
oluştururlar ama kovalent bağlı bileşik
oluşturdukları iyon olmaz orada böyle
yükseltgenme basamağı ifade ifadesi
geçer ki onu da zaten nerede modern atom
teorisinde yükseltgenme basamakları
kısmında detaylı bir şekilde anlatıyor
yarı metaller Ya bak adı üstünde yarı
Metal ne Metal ne ametal şöyledir
Aslında en güzel kodlaması şudur yarı
metal için fiziksel olarak metale benzer
kimyasal olarak da [__] metale benzer
Burada da onu söylüyor işte kimyasal
özellikleri [__] metale fiziksel
özellikleri metallere benzer Periyodik
tabloda işte 3A grubunda Bor 4A grubunda
silisyum germanyum Ondan sonra 5A
grubunda arsenik Eee başka antimon Tell
polonyum astatin şeklinde söyleyebiliriz
astatin Birazcık böyle şeydir muallak
dadır ama sonuç olarak bunlar yarı metal
olarak geçmektedir Eee yarı metaller
parlak ya da mat olabilmektedirler
bileşiklerinde pozitif veya negatif
değerlik alabilmektedirler elektriği
metallerden az [__] metallerden fazla il
etmektedirler yarı iletken özellikleri
vardır bunların ki birçok Eee Çevrenizde
gördüğümüz Çipler şunlar buna silikon
çip deriz değil mi İşte yarı metallerden
yapılmaktadır bunları germanyum la
arsenikle şunla bununla desteklemektedir
ki o yarı iletken enlik özellikleri
değişsin yarı iletkenler O yüzden günlük
hayatta elektronik eşyalarda çok çok
değerlidir onu da bilmemiz lazım katı
haldedirler ve
işlenebilmesi halde bulunurlar bu ifade
önemlidir değerlik elektron sayıları
helyum hariç 8'dir bir tek helyumun
2'dir Onun dışında bileşik yapmaya
yatkın değildirler kararlı yapıdadırlar
kimyasal kararlılıkları vardır O da
koşullarında tek atomlu gaz halinde
olduğunu söylemiştik erime ve kaynama
noktaları düşüktür gaz halinde adı
üstünde Çünkü kararlı yapıdadırlar ve
ışıklandırma sistemlerinde kullanırlar
yani ona elektrik enerjisi verdiğinde
Işık yaymaya başlamaktadırlar böyle
özellikleri vardır bakalım şimdi Bununla
ilgili ÖSYM Ne sormuş bir tane soru
gelmiş diyor ki çekirdek için kırmızı
elektronlar için mavi renk kullanılarak
bir elementin nötr atomunun katman
elektron dağılımı modellenmiştir çok
güzel Buna göre hangisi doğrudur şimdi
bu modele bakarsak Eğer birinci katmanda
2 elektron var 2de 8 elektron var 3
katmanda da 2 elektron var Yani bu 3
periyot yazalım 2A grubu
elementiyle 2A grubunda bulunur ve 3ün
periyottadır gitti 2ci periyottadır
Hayır 3 periyottadır 2A grubundadır
burayı zıt kullanmış Gördüğün gibi
bileşik oluştururken metal olduğu için
elektron vermeye yatkındır Doğrudur
cevap da e seçeneği olacaktır o zaman
soru çözelim de şu işi iyice
pekiştirelim birinci sorumuz da ne diyor
periyodik sistemle ilgili olarak
ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur diyor
günümüzdeki periyodik sistemle Mendel'in
periyodik sistemi tamamen aynıdır diyor
Hayır canım mozley inini kullanıyoruz Bu
atom kütlesine göre diziyor Biz atom
numarasına göre diziyoruz o yüzden bu
yanlıştır diyor ki içerdiği metallerin
sayısı ametallerden fazladır Evet
Periyodik tabloda metal sayısı çok
fazladır Doğrudur elementlerin proton
sayısı ve kimyasal özellikleri dikkate
alınarak oluşturulmuştur Evet mozley bu
şekilde oluşturmuştu Doğrudur şöyle
söyleyeyim
ile ilgili bir tane Detay verecektim bu
adama yüzmeyi öğretmiş olabiliriz ama
yüzemediğini için de biz öldürmüş
olabiliriz biliyorsunuz şeyde periyodik
tablonun mucidi şu anki günümüzde
kullandığımız periyodik tablonun mucidi
Ama bu adam e Çanakkale Savaşı'na
geliyor Çanakkale savaşına subay olarak
Katılıyor Bizimkiler ayırt etmez
biliyorsunuz yani Yüzme öğrenmek
isteyeni orada denize döker yani acımaz
Bizimkilerden birisi büyük ihtimalle
üniversitelilerden bir tanesi şöyle
yapmış olabilir bakmıştır la şu Moz
değil mi la demiş diye vurmuştur büyük
ihtimalle yani eee Sen benim ülkemi
almaya geliyorsan Kusura bakma mozley
yani bilim adamı dinlemeyiz Biz
indiririz aşağıya Yani biz ülkemizi
savunan insanlarız Yani orada Bilmiyorum
artık nerede yatıyor da e kendi ülkesine
götürmüşlerdir Zaten ondan sonra da
galiba Bilim insanlarının savaşa
katılmasını Yasaklıyor iyi bir karar
olmuş yani bizim sayemizde dünya çapında
güzel bir karar alınmış oluyor çünkü Eee
Senin görevin bilim yapmak insanı
öldürmek değil sen Görevini yap ki
insanlığa faydan olsun değil mi dostum
Hadi sorulara devam edelim He Biz cevabı
ne bulduk 2 ve 3 bulduk yani B seçeneği
2de diyor ki çekirdek yükü 20 olan x
atomunun + 2 yüklü taneciğinin elektron
katman dizilimi Aşağıdakilerden
hangisinde doğru verilmiştir bir dakika
çekirdek yükü 20 yani proton sayısı 20
20'yi yazdık + 2 yüklüydü çok güzel
Bunun elektron dizilimini soruyor Bu
halinin + 2 diyorsa + 2 ile kaçı
toplarsam 20 eder 18 zaten + 2 demek 2
Elektron vermiş demektir artıların
sayısı eksilerden fazla olması lazım ya
E o zaman ne olacak burası 10 8'e göre
yazılacak 2 8 8 Aha da budur cevabımız
da A seçeneğidir ama periyodik tablodaki
yeri nedir deseydi Aha Buna göre
yapacaktık tamam mı dostum 3te diyor ki
periyodik Yukarıdaki periyodik sistemde
yerleri belirtilen elementlerle ilgili
ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur demiş
burada bana neyi vermiş 1A grubunda x'i
yazmış hidrojendir bu hidrojen yani
ametal Bununla ilgili kesin bir detay
vardır Ona bakarız şimdi bakalım şu
arada olan geçiş metali şöyle geçiş
metali bunu da yazdık Burası da 6a grubu
tamam belirttik diyor ki Z elementi oda
koşullarında diatomik moleküler halde
bulunur diyor ev Z elementi 6a grubunun
ilk elementi Bu neydi oksijendir doğada
molekül halinde yani O2 halinde
bulunuyor diatomik halde bulunuyor
Doğrudur diyor ki x v'nin kimyasal
özellikleri benzerdir Hayır ikisi
Normalde Aynı gruptaki elementlerin
kimyasal özellikleri benzerdir ama
hidrojen ametal y burada metaldir alkali
metaldir bunların kimyasal
özelliklerinde benzerlik yoktur O yüzden
gitti T geçiş metalidir Doğrudur cevap
Ne oldu 1 ve 3 oldu yani C seçeneği 4te
diyor ki yukarıdaki tabloda bulunan
elementlerden hangilerinin karşısındaki
özelliği doğru verilmiştir diyor H hı
hım bakalım bunun elektron dizilimi 2'ye
5 yani 2ci katmanında 1ci katmana K
katmanı ikinci katmana L katmanı diyoruz
l katmanında 5 elektron bulunur ifadesi
ne oldu doğru oldu hani katmanlar
böyleydi ya k l m n işte 1in katman
ikinci katman 3 4 la gözükmüyor He şöyle
gösterim o şekilde olduğu için K katmanı
2ci katmandır bunda da 2 elektron Pardon
kaç 5 elektron bulunmaktadır nasıl
konuşamıyorum ha E buna bakalım 2 8 8 1
çok güzel bulunduğu periyodun ilk
elementidir e 1A grubu ilk element değil
mi bulunduğu periyottaki ilk element
değil mi doğrudur Bunu da geçtik diyor
ki flor 9 2'ye 7 bir elektron alarak 2
periyot soygazın elektron dizilimine
ulaşır 2 periyot soygaz 2'ye 8'dir 7'di
8'e ulaşması için bir elektron alması
lazım yani bu ifade de doğrudur cevap 1
2 3 oldu yani e seçeneği 5te diyor ki
Yukarıdaki ifadelerden hangileri
doğrudur h h h Soygazlar kararlı yapıda
olduklarından bileşik oluşturmazlar
süper bir doğru yani genel olarak doğru
onu da söyleyeyim çünkü istisnai
örnekleri var ama bir genelleme olduğu
için bunu doğru kabul edebilirim
lantanit ve aktinit lere iç geçiş
metalleri ya da iç geçiş elementleri
diyoruz Bu da doğrudur Toprak
metallerinin değerlik elektron sayısı
3'tür Doğrudur bak Toprak alkali metal
2A grubudur Toprak metali 3A grubudur 3A
grubunun da değerlik elektron sayısı 3
olduğu için doğrudur cevap Ne oldu 1 2 3
e seçeneği oldu 6 sorumuza geldik çok
güzel Bakalım x y z element atomları ile
ilgili ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur
diyor Bu ne 3ün periyot son katmanda 4
elektron var 4A grubu e şuna bakarsak 1
2 3 3 periyot 2A grubu bu ise 1 periyot
2A değildi neydi 8A grubuyuz sadece bir
periyot varsa ve elektron sayısı 2 ise
buna Ne diyorduk Biz 8 A grubu elementi
helyumdan grubu silisyum elementidir ki
bu yarı metaldir şöyle yazalım yarı
metal E bu Toprak alkali metal Toprak
alkali metal onu da belirtelim E bu
zaten soygaz bakalım bunlarla ilgili
bilgiler var mı diyor ki y ve z Toprak
alkali metalidir Hayır Z soygazdan diyor
ki X ve Y aynı periyottadır Evet ikisi
de 3 periyottadır Doğrudur x ametal
diyor Hayır yarı metal y metal o kısımda
doğru Z asal gazdır Tamam şu ikisi doğru
ama x ametal ifadesi yanlıştır cevap Ne
oldu yalnız 2 A seçeneği oldu 7 sorumuza
bakalım Diyor ki bana metal ve
ametallerle ilgili bir şema vermiş
Burada bazı bilgiler vermiş hangileri
doğru yere yerleştirilmiştir diyor
metaller elektriği iletir Evet bu doğru
yere yerleştirilmiş çok güzel tel ve
levha haline getirilebilir Evet metaller
için doğru bir ifadedir Bu da doğru yere
yerleştirilmiş tamamı baş gruplarda
bulunur Bir dakika metaller B
gruplarında da bulunur yani bunun yeri
yanlış ametaller Sadece a gr gruplarında
bulunur yani baş gruplarda bulunur 2'nin
yeri yanlış Tamam çok güzel periyodik
sistemde her grupta bulunur diyor
ametaller için 1ci grupta 1A grubunda
var mı var hidrojen var ama 2A grubunda
yok 3A grubunda yok e b gruplarında da
yok demek ki bunun de yeri yanlıştır
doğruları soruyor 1 ve 3 olmalı yani B
seçeneği 8de ne demiş diyor ki x -4
iyonu ile y 32'ye -2 iyonu izoelektronik
dir diyor yani elektron sayıları aynı
proton sayıları farklı y'nin nükleon
sayısı Proton sayısının 2i katı eşit
olduğuna göre Hım nötr x atomunun
elektron dizilimi nedir diye soruyor
şimdi y'nin diyor ki neyi nükleon sayısı
yani kütle numarası 32 Proton sayısının
2 katıymış o zaman proton sayısı 16
oluyor değil mi 2 katı olduğuna göre E
demek ki bunun nötron sayısı da 16 çok
güzel bu -2 yüklü olduğuna göre bak 16
şurası -2 elektron sayısı kaç olmalı ki
-2 ile e'yi topladığımda 16 etsin 18
değil mi izoelektronik diyorsa elektron
sayıları aynıydı x - 4'ün 18 tane
elektronu varmış Çok güzel o zaman bunun
proton sayısı kaç oldu 14 oldu çünkü -4
ile 18'i topladım Burası 14 oldu bana
nötr x atomunun elektron dizilimini
Soruyor yani 14'e göre yazacağım 2 8 10
etti geriye ne kaldı 4 2 8 4 cevabım D
seçeneği 9 güzel bir soru xo3 -3
iyonunun toplam elektron sayısı 50'dir
hangileri doğrudur şimdi xo3 üzeri -3
xo4 üzeri Pardon xo4 üzeri -3 böyle
demektir bu parantez hepsini
kapsamaktadır Toplam 50 elektronu varmış
şöyle düşünelim renk değiştirdim X'in
proton sayısı eşit elektron sayısı demek
desek ona x dedik dedik diyelim Oksijen
kaç 8 4 tane olduğu için 32 Buradan da
bu geldi -3 ne demekti dışarıdan 3
elektron almıştı bunu da ekledim Toplam
50 elektron olduğunu söylüyor o zaman
x'i buradan 15 bulduk Demek ki nötr X'in
15 protonu varmış 15 de elektronu varmış
nö x elementi ile ilgili olarak atom
numarası 15'tir doğru Elon dizilimini
15'e göre yazarsak 2 8 5 3 periyot 5
a'dır 3 katman var son katmanda 5
elektron var o yüzden 3 periyot 5A dır
çok güzel x + 5 iyonu periyodik sistemde
3 periyot 8A grubu soygaz ile
izoelektronik diyor bak x 15'i + 5'i Hım
o zaman bunun 10 elektronu var demektir
3 periyot soy gazı demek 2 8 8 demektir
yani 18 oluyor e Bunlar izoelektronik
Olur mu olmaz Ben nereye bakıyorsam
buraya niye baktım ha buraya bakmam
gerekiyor 18 Olur mu olmaz o yüzden
üçüncüsü yanlış Biz doğruları arıyoruz
cevabımız B seçeneği olacak Dostum
geldik 10 sorumuza diyor ki aşağıdaki
elementlerden hangisi Yukarıdaki
herhangi bir özelliğe sahip değildir H
toprak metalidir toprak metali dediği 3A
grubu yarı metaldir diyor Dur geleceğiz
önce şuna bakalım Toprak metali 3A grubu
arıyorum bak aha 2 8 3 Toprak metalidir
bu var Yarım metaldir diyor yarım
metaller bildiğim Bor var silisyum var
germanyum var Aha silisyum Gözüküyor bak
2 8 4 4 periyodun 2ci elementi
silisyumlu yarı metal di Demek ki bu da
var silisyumu buraya yazdık alüminyumu
buraya yazdık bunu da eledik diyor ki
kararlı yapıda olduklarından oda
koşullarında bileşikleri yoktur yani
soygazdan bahsediyor burada neon var bak
2 2'ye 8 Yani bu da
soygazdan grubunda yani 7A grubunda yer
alır diyor bak 2 8 7 bu da var ama
sodyumla ilgili yani 1A grubu ile ilgili
bilgi var mı Yok cevabım da a seçeneği
olacak Dostum 11'e geldik Bakalım 11'de
diyor ki x + 1 iyonunun katman elektron
dizilimi 2 8 8 şeklindedir diyor nötr x
element atomu ile ilgili olarak diyor
hemen rengi değiştiriyorum x + 1 halinin
2 8 8 olduğunu söylüyor yani 18
elektronu varmış o zaman + 1 18 Daha
bunun Proton sayısının 19 olduğunu
buldum e 19 İsa nötr x'ten bahsediyor
yani Art ık 19'a göre bakacağım 2 8 8 1
4 periyot 1A grubu olmalı 3 periyot 1A
demiş yanlış diyor ki değerlik elektron
sayısı 1'dir Evet son katmandaki
elektron sayısı 1 olduğu için doğru ve
1A grubunda olduğu için hidrojen hariç
metal di O yüzden metaldir doğru Biz de
doğruları arıyoruz cevabımız 2 ve 3 D
seçeneği olacaktır 12'de ne diyor
periyodik sistemde ikinci periyot ve
sonrası için atom numaraları
soygazlardan bir eksik olan grup ve bu
gruptaki elementler ile ilgili
soygazlardan bir eksik yani 8 A'dan bir
eksik 7A grubu elementlerinden
bahsediyor yani halojenlerden bahsediyor
birincisi Doğrudur bulundukları
periyodun en aktif [__] metallerdir Evet
7A grubu aktif ametalleri içermektedir
Doğrudur değerlik elektron sayısı 7A
grubunda 7'dir Bu da doğrudur cevabımız
1 2 3 e seçeneği olacaktır Evet dostum
ne yapmış olduk periyodik sistemle
ilgili ilk kısmımız bitirmiş olduk
bundan sonraki dersimizde ne yapacağız
periyodik özelliklerden bahsedeceğiz
beni dinlediğin için Teşek Teşekkür
ederim ödevlerini bitirmeyi unutma soru
bankasından Bu konuyla ilgili şu ana
kadar geldiğimiz yerle ilgili soruları
çöz çöz bitir ki birikmesin dostum Bak
birikince ne oluyor biliyor musun yapma
isteğin gidiyor yani konuyu çalıştın
peşine hemen soruyu çöz ki erit gitsin
kitabı da bitirmiş olacaksın Bu Da Sana
mutluluk verecek ya hocam işte çok kalın
kitap ya kitabın son sayfasına bakmayın
dostum ya gerçekten bak alıyorsunuz
kitabı şöyle Baktın O nasıl bitecek bu
kitap diye son sayfa ya boş ver ya bak
özellikle ne yaptık Çek Kopar şeklinde
yaptık değil mi sen şu ana kadarki
gördüğümüz kısım var ya yırt oraları
yırt yanına al sadece o kısmı çöz at
kitaba hiç bakma zaten çek koparlı ya
senin için de güzel olacak böyle yavaş
yavaş bitireceksin la kamp bittiğinde
bir bakacaksın ki kitap da bitmiş
muhteşem bir keyiftir bak bunu sakın
unutma Yani dediğimi yap kopara kopara
git ya kenara koy çöz kenara koy çöz
kenara koy sene sonunda o atma ha bak
bunların hiçbirini atmayın kenara yığın
bunları çözdüğünüz her şeyi belki
anneniz fırça atabilir veya işte
evdekiler fırça atabilir bilemiyorum ama
şu var sene sonu bunların hepsini alın
böyle mangalda mı yakıyorsunuz veya işte
üst üste koyup fotoğraf mı çekiliyorsun
çok keyifli bir şeydir onu söyleyeyim
size veya işte Okulda Bazen öyle şovlar
yapılıyor Çok da güzel oluyor hepiniz
mesela götürürsünüz şeyden koridordan
aşağıya atarsınız böyle şeyden e neydi
onun ismi merdivenlerden aşağıya böyle O
da toplu halde atınca Çok da keyifli olu
sonradan toplatır sizi ama olsun yani
ayrı bir keyiftir yani ne yapıyorsun Bak
geldiğin yere kadar çözüyorsun o kamp
programı var ya verdiğim kamp programı
oradaki tak takip ederek ödev programını
oraya göre çöz at kenara çöz at kenara
birikmesin kitap da birikmesin ödevler
biriktiği için senin moralin de
bozulmasın çok da Faydasını göreceksin
dostum kitaplar gerçekten çok iyi İlla
benim kitabı çözmek zorunda değilsin
tabii ki başka kitaplar da alabilirsin
Hocam ben kitap alamıyorum Tamam OGM
materyal var Aç oradan çöz veya ben
çözerken Durdur ekranı çöz Ondan sonra
devam ettir böyle de olur yani
alamıyorsan çözüm var zaten konu
anlatımı kısmını ben ücretsiz PDF olarak
veriyorum soru kısımlarını vermiyorum
veya soru Bankasını da aynı şekilde
veremiyorum hocalarımın emekleri olduğu
için eğer hani o hocalarıma da destek
olmak isterseniz linkini şuraya
bırakıyorum oradan indirip Daha doğrusu
linkini indiremiyor Daha doğrusu oradan
kitabı Satın alıp hocalarıma da destek
olabilirsin dostum onu da buradan
söylemiş olayım Evet ne diyoruz iki
fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşça kal